maybe this is a good story for aspiring
screenwriters out there when I when I
went to work with with Michael McDowell
on Beetlejuice we had been working for a
couple of weeks and he sat down and he
said Larry this is not working out this
is not happening
and I was taken aback and I said why
what do you mean he said because you're
just sitting around waiting for
inspiration and I don't work like that
I'm not I'm not going to sit around
waiting for you to be inspired if you're
going to work with me and Michael was
this professional writer as I ever met
he had published I don't know
19 20 novels novels genre novels
he had written for a show called tales
from the dark side he was the real deal
and and and and and not a not not a pro
not not a person to to hold back his
feelings okay
any any and again he said to me this is
just not happening and and he said and
this was the most this changed my my
life as a writer he said if you're going
to work with me look at it like we're
working in a bank we get in at 9:00 we
have a cup of coffee we say good morning
we then we go to work and we were and we
write until lunch we go have our lunch
we come back we write again till around
three o'clock in the afternoon we fold
up the writing we return whatever phone
calls whatever business of writing we
have to do and we do this five six days
a week and we ran and it's a job it's
it's not you sitting in it with a
metaphorical beret in a metaphorical
loft waiting for inspiration to strike
it's a job and it was a bit of tough
love and it took me back
and I suppose a tiny bit offended but
then then the thing he said to me that
sealed the deal because I when I was
working at Paramount I was writing
script notes again it was it was like a
16-hour day often and in probably
fourteen of those hours a day was
writing script notes and he said Larry
you've told me you've written hundreds
of pages of notes for other people's
scripts why can't you do it for yourself
and I was like wow okay I will try it
your way
and it changed my perception of who a
writer is what a writer does and it
changed my work habits and it changed
everything and I did it his way and I
took all of that all and he was
absolutely right all of that discipline
that I put into other people's work I
put in I started putting the my work on
work and and and it was and beatings
came out of that and is crazy and you
know and as far out of that movie is the
script was written in a very disciplined
way because that was the way Michael
needed to work
you